Okay, London.
KENDALL ROY: London. All of us?
What are we, a fucking octopus
giving, like, reach-arounds
to-- to every fish
on the reef now, or?
All right, relax,
Branzino Pornoman.
LOGAN ROY: It's fine. It's fine.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
It was a very fun episode
for me 'cause I was working
with Becky Martin,
who's the director,
and we were over in England
a little bit
and in Scotland quite a lot.
So yeah, it was
an enjoyable episode to make,
although there's some very,
very unfunny scenes in it.
LOGAN: Will you come with me?
As in?
Down to the boy's family.
I think we knew from early on,
we were gonna do an episode
where we wanted to come back
at the tragic events
of the end
of the previous season,
but not
in a terribly direct way.
-Come in.
-(PASSENGER DOOR OPENS)
When we were shooting it,
Jeremy inhabits Kendall so fully
that it felt very heavy
and distressing to see him
be there and look
at the minutiae
of a destroyed family's lives.
Do you think that
I should maybe...
-say something to them?
-No.
I guess that's the terrible
tragedy for Kendall
is that it's not a way for him
to do what he would really like
to do, which is...
accept some
of the guilt he feels.
-GREG HIRSCH: Hey, Tom.
-Hey, Greg. How ya doing?
One thing that's nice for us
through the season
is you see what Greg does
when he starts earning
a bit more money and he feels
more comfortable in his skin.
You played your hand very well.
I like it. But we need
to end this now.
Or I tell Logan that you took
copies of sensitive documents.
Their relationship is in
that weird area
where it's somewhat
transactional.
They test each other out
to the limits
of where they can rely
on each other.
-How did it come to this, huh?
-Uh-huh.
GREG:
Put on the disappearing sauce.
Sauce it. Sauce it.
Greg's got a decision to make
about where he jumps in the end.
Hey, Rhea.
Dad, Rhea's here.
Not a big deal.
In terms of Logan
and Rhea's relationship,
we liked seeing a different kind
of connection.
Yikes.
Fucking coochie fucking coo.
It's not a side to him that
we've shown in the show before.
He can turn on his charm,
and also, that he himself
can be... charmed.
-I'd value your thoughts.
-On the kids?
Who's got it? Huh?
(CHUCKLES) I could do
with a clear eye.
JESSE ARMSTRONG:
Why does Logan take to her?
Part of it is that feeling
of like... (CLICKS TONGUE)
"Great, this person can sort
everything out."
I think I might be able
to help you make this go away.
ARMSTRONG: Their relationship
is complicated,
but for the kids,
it's quite a definitive,
danger sign flashing.
There's a lot of different ways
that can fall out.
-SHIV ROY: Is she on the plane?
-KENDALL: Uh-huh.
I think we got a problem.
Just be careful.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪